police with axes and assault rifles
raided this venue in sao paulo and found
about 600 party-goers
most without masts most unrepentant
we pay taxes and we know the risks we
may get sick or infect our family but we
need to do something in life
the police said the venue had no windows
and all the doors were closed
elsewhere in sao paulo they also
uncovered a clandestine vip casino
where among the revelers was
international brazilian footballer
gabriel barbosa
the country is collapsing hospitals are
overcrowded and people are still playing
and gathering at the forbidden event
with more than 11 million people
infected
and 277 000 deaths hospitals in brazil
are struggling to cope
12 000 people died in the past week
alone
only the united states has been hit
harder
we saw a family being destroyed not long
ago father mother
grandfather grandmother everyone
suffered in the family so it's very sad
the state government of sao paulo with a
population of 44 million
has imposed new emergency measures
including a nighttime curfew
a ban on sporting events and the closure
of all non-essential businesses
there to last a minimum of 15 days
but protesters many of them supporters
of president john bolsonaro
took to the streets to oppose the
measures
we're protesting against the dictatorial
attitude of the governor
his lockdown will put an end to our jobs
our health and to the people of sao
paulo
meanwhile the operation to vaccinate
brazil's 211 million people
has been slow to get going one who has
is the 75 year old former president
popularly known as lula
i hope this vaccine gives the result
that i dream of that the brazilian
people dream of
because all they want is to be
vaccinated against this monster called
coronavirus
the president needs to stop being so
ignorant while some fight the pandemic
others brazenly defy it the only
certainty
is that brazil's coronavirus casualties
continue to rise
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires